es sólo el último episodio de un patrón
trágicamente recurrente en argelia los
incendios forestales han arrasado 14
provincias del norte del país en los
últimos días dejando un rastro de
destrucción y muerte a su paso
los incendios comenzaron en cuatro
regiones incluyendo gicl posiblemente
esté relacionado con el clima pero no
sólo eso estamos llevando a cabo un
investigación para conocer las razones
precisas de estos incendios la verdadera
pregunta que se ha planteado es por qué
varios incendios comenzaron al mismo
tiempo en su cara so card y dj y es la
investigación la que puede iluminarnos
leyendo a los ojos la gendarmería cerró
varias carreteras mientras que
helicópteros descargaban agua sobre los
incendios en tres zonas incluyendo el
municipio de su caras unas 350 personas
fueron evacuadas de la ciudad situada
cerca de la frontera con túnez en total
desde principios de agosto ha habido 106
incendios forestales en argelia que han
destruido 2500 hectáreas de bosques
y aunque estos incendios destructivos
eran antes algo relativamente raro en el
país norteafricano cada vez son más
frecuentes en parte debido al cambio
climático
en el verano de 2021 se produjeron
algunos de los peores incendios
forestales de los últimos años con al
menos 90 muertos y más de 100 mil
hectáreas de bosque quemadas
un saldo devastador para un país en el
que menos del 1 por ciento de la tierra
cuenta con árboles